you've heard the phrase a lot lately
Democratic Socialist it's suddenly very
common on the Left Bernie Sanders has
called himself the Democratic Socialist
so his New York congressional candidate
Alexandria Acacio Cortez she's the woman
the DNC chair Tom Perez recently said
this about she represents the future of
our party Alexandria's victory was a
just a remarkable reminder of the depth
that we have in the Democratic Party
okay so democratic socialism is the
future but what is democratic socialism
we thought it'd be worth pausing for a
minute to find out democratic socialism
is not by the way a wing of the
Democratic Party at least not yet it's
an entirely separate movement with its
own national organization the Democratic
socialists of America two years ago the
DSA endorsed Bernie Sanders and opposed
Donald Trump but did not endorse Hillary
Clinton so at times it has been
antagonistic to the Democratic Party
what did democratic socialists believe
there's no formal platform but the
outlines are pretty clear Democratic
socialists support socialism state
ownership of major industries that would
include health care technology
manufacturing some of them explicitly
support communism the co-chair Portland
Oregon's chapter of the DSA recently
tweeted this quote as ADSA chapter
co-chair I just want to set the record
straight for a minute communism is good
but democratic socialism is about more
than economics the DSA's official
Twitter account demands reparations for
african-americans in the form of free
and open enrollment at public colleges
retroactive forgiveness of student loans
and a guaranteed lifetime minimum income
the DSA is also called for an end to all
immigrant deportations everywhere in the
United States in New York the DSA has
demanded the abolition of profits
prisons cash bail and borders not all
democratic socialists have the same
views on everything but that gives you
some idea unlimited uncontrolled
immigration into the u.s. coupled with
race-based reparations the abolition of
prisons and by extension law and order
itself any massive expansion of the
welfare state financed by an economic
system that does not recognize profit
how would that work exactly has it ever
worked in any country in the world
though suddenly seem like relevant
questions at this pace democratic
socialists could get the
patek nomination at some point and be
elected president so we thought was a
perfect moment to speak to possibly the
most famous of all advocates for
democratic socialism Cornel West he's
professor at Harvard he's an honorary
co-chair of the Democratic socialists of
America and he joins us tonight Cornel
thank you for coming on no thank you and
it's good to be in dialogue with you
want to once again not run yes it is
so to give us some sense of what
democratic socialism is can you point to
an example an extant example of it that
works Venezuela seems like an example of
democratic socialism would you say that
it is and if so does it work no I don't
think that democratic socialism as an
ideal has been able to be embodied in a
larger social context there's different
forms of it some are bad some are medium
some work better but the fundamental
commitment is to the dignity of ordinary
people and to make sure they can live
lives of decency so it's not an ism no
brother it's about decency it's about
fairness it's about the accountability
of the powerful visa vie those who have
less power at the workplace women
dealing with the household gays lesbians
trans black people indigenous peoples
immigrants how do we ensure that they
are treated decently and that the
powerful don't in any way manipulate
subjugate and exploit them well I mean
if that's what democratic socialism is
that I'm basically on board I do think
that ordinary people middle-class people
ought to have dignity and I think that
our current systems make it hard for
them to have dignity so I grab solution
but the details in that precisely why
that's why Albert Einstein Helen Helen
Keller Norman Thomas Eugene Debs Martin
Luther King jr. Ella Baker we can go on
and on they're all democratic socialists
Michael Harrington one of the great
founders of this understand but has it
struck you as interesting that it's
never actually worked anywhere so the
question is not water or metals our
goals are the same quest how do we get
there is the question so what happened
in Venezuela they call that democratic
socialism but they don't have toilet
paper and it's less equal than ever that
but part of the problem is though
at any time there's been the attempts of
ordinary people to engage in
self-determination they can get crushed
by external nation look at US policies
toward Venezuela has been very very ugly
Nicaragua in the same way we saw that in
so many other instances where countries
try to engage in self-determination and
either get crushed they either get
coerced and they end up oftentimes
responding to that kind of authoritarian
treatment so we've never had a chance to
really pull it off so it's only been a
movement so far it's an attempt to
resist the greed at the top the racism
the sexism the homophobia the various
ways in which human manatee is violated
rather than affirmed so here's just to
the details quickly the the DSA of New
York which is certainly one of the
biggest in the country recently God for
sister Alexandria she's might be
assistant comrade so they said that
they're against boarders profits and
prisons
what would a country without prisons
look like what would you do with
murderers for example a rapist where
would you put them with no prisons well
I'm going to say prisons they're talking
about the kinds of prisons we have at
the present if you have sites of
rehabilitation education ways in which
transformation can take place you and I
our selves and you Episcopalian I'm
Baptist we're Christians right we
believe all human beings made not just
in every image of God but they can be
changed they can't be transformed when
the right kind of intervention takes
place that's what people mean in the
socialist move when they talk about the
elimination of the kind of prisons that
are in place so what they really have
mattered and raping okay so what about
borders though you should have isolation
you can have distance but you don't give
up on them and most importantly you
don't view them in the vicious that
through the lens of being less than
human that they can bounce back they can
be better so if a government's
obligation is to its own citizens and
you drop the borders and have no border
enforcement at all what would happen to
this country what would happen to the
poor people in this country with their
lives get better would they become more
prosperous no this kind
become poorer dirtier impossible to
manage it would be flooded with the poor
of the world and it would destroy our
country instantly so why would you say
no borders well that mean again though
you've got a variety of voices in the
Democratic Socialist of America we like
a jazz orchestra you got different
perspectives and orientations we all
don't agree on one particular policy all
the time this is true in terms of
Israeli occupation of Palestinians some
are in the middle some are much more
critical like myself the question is how
do you keep track of the rich Humanity
of Mexican brothers and sisters of those
coming from Latin America those coming
from Africa
those coming from Haiti and those coming
from Europe and Asia that's the
important thing we know the history of
America that indigenous peoples and
Africans who've been enslaved was to
open the borders the bring folk in to
how do you think but it's not a matter
of no borders at all it's a matter of
how do you ensure that their dignity is
affirmed when they arrive so that you
don't end up as we have neo-fascist
policies of the Trump administration
separating these precious children from
their their mothers a slice that's silly
as you well know but how do you think
that the descendants what Americans say
what's it like
the descendants of American slaves
benefit when you bring in 25 million
illegals illegal immigrants from the
third world does that elevate poor
Americans I don't see any evidence that
they get rich or happier when you bring
in more poor people you ignore their
problems that's why we don't pay any
attention but if we were having this
discussion 100 years ago and you had
millions of people coming from
jew-hating Europe Irish hating Britain
and Ireland I mean all the folk who came
into the making of slices of this nation
they did not allow for the kind of
coming together with poor and working
people would be able to straighten their
backs up and speak with dignity and
decency about issues that affect all of
us that's the history of the nation with
the exception of the African slaves and
the precious indigenous peoples so the
idea that somehow now that the
immigrants are here and a lot of the
immigrants have only been here one or
two generations now become the
finish of authority defining what it is
to be an American how hypocritical can
you get I've been here nine generations
coming out of enslaved people and I can
still embrace my Mexican brothers and
sisters I can embrace the whole host of
others coming from around myself as a
question of making sure their dignity as
a firm when they get hit and you've got
to get a hold of the DSA of New York's
Twitter account because they're saying
well we got a number of voices and ESA a
Glover we believe a disagreement we
believe in this with you were just
talking about disagreement in terms of
defending civil liberties I believe in
protecting civil liberties yours mines
courageous bernie sanders Mumia
abu-jamal 'he's a whole host of folk or
doubt coming on i hope you will come
back Cornel West